hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
early identification of target
candidates for pancreatic adenosarconoma
immunotherapy
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltenny biotech to learn more
visit miltennybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
olaf hart
senior manager of research and
development miltoni biotech olaf you may
now begin your presentation
thank you for joining my
presentation today about the early
identification of target candidates for
pancreatic adenocarcinoma immunotherapy
as probably all of you are aware car t
cell therapies really have gained
a lot of interest because of the
tremendous efficacies in treating in
particular hematopoietic malignancies
over the last years
a very prominent example being all right
now also cd19 directly car t cells have
gained fda approval recently and really
show a nice example of cellular
immunotherapy efficacy
however so far this success is really
limited to hematopoietic malignancies
such as al and some others whereas
there's very limited success in treating
solid tumors and that has a
range of reasons such as a very
immunosuppressive immune micro
environment
but also the lack of known target
structures which you have for example
here in all there is the lineage marker
cd90 that is expressed on almost all of
the tumor cells in many of or most of
the patients but this is not the case
when you have solid tumors and in
particular also these healthy cells
which are also targeted because they
express cd19 are actually dispensable
meaning the car t cells that eradicate
the tumor cells and also eradicate the
healthy b cells um is still an option
because you can do this by a
therapy intervention that can still um
be tolerated well by the patients and
that is not the cases in many solid
tumors because the
structures that are expressed on these
solid tumor epithelial cells are also
expressed on cells of other healthy
organs that are not dispensable
so let's briefly go into the principle
of car t-cell therapies so this here is
shown for an autologous setting where
the patient is actually undergoing a
leukopheresis the t cells are separated
from the leukopheresis and are then
x-vivo modified genetically engineered
to express the car or the camera antigen
receptor on the surface this is mostly
done by lentivirus but also mrna and
other methods can be applied
afterwards the cells are further
activated and expanded to huge amounts
which are then reinfused back into the
patient where the cartesians can
efficiently migrate to the tumor cells
and then kill them by a
recognition of the cell surface molecule
expressed on the cancer cell by the car
and then afterwards cytokine release and
also active killing of the cancer cells
and on the right hand side you can also
see a little bit of differences between
a t cell receptor mediated and car
mediated
targeting
so both have advantages and
disadvantages for example the car is
very efficient in treating
cell surface marker based
approaches because it is not restricted
to mhc molecules so it's independent on
the haplotype of the patient so
basically the same targets can be
applied that you can also apply by
biologics such as antibodies or bytes
however the disadvantage is of course
that you can only target cell surface
structures whereas for t cell receptors
you can also target intracellular
structures
and even mutated antigens because they
are presented in mhc fashion so today i
will focus purely on car t cells
and as mentioned one of the major
bottlenecks is the strategy for
identification of the best therapeutic
targets which have to be cell surface
targets and we over the last couple of
years have really worked a lot on this
for different two medications today as
mentioned focuses on pancreatic ductile
adenocarcinoma
and we have developed this strategy here
where we start with solid tissues either
from patient derived
mouse models xenograft models often
primary human specimens and as jana
already pointed out did this here by
high throughput screening of cell
surface antigens by flow cytometry in
order to narrow down the amount of
markers that are of interest and then do
a further spatial identification of
these
marker candidates let's say in the
tissue context and this leads to the
selection of top candidates for further
downstream functional evaluation
so let's go into this a little bit more
and deeply uh because here you see also
a little bit more the the initial early
workflow uh where we started screening
of about four net antibodies for binding
on pancreatic tumor cells and therefore
we have also used 19 different patients
who have xenograft models and this has
advantages here tumor material is not
limiting meaning that you can easily do
flow cytometry based screenings and do
parallel analysis of single samples for
screening antibody
whereas in the second course when you
then want to go more into the validation
mode
and you want to do this on primary tumor
but also in particular on healthy tissue
specimens in order to identify potential
on target of tumor toxicities really the
tissue becomes the limiting factor and
here we have done sequential screening
by immunofluorescence and i will also
briefly talk about this later
but first of all let's talk about the
icon the
screening by flow cytometry
see again we splitted this up as
mentioned we started with pdx model
having hundreds of millions of cells
and then we applied these screening
plates that we provide among screening
plates and then also a
narrow demarca number down
to a more com more narrower data set and
then i also screened many more uh pdx
models again and this all was done by
flow cytometry and then after narrowing
down the marker of candidates we have
also worked even with flow cytometry
with primary tissue specimens
which were coming from surgical
resections of primary tumors and then
have also stained them by flow cytometry
so of course when you want to do flow
cytometry based screening you have to
have a very efficient way to get a
single suspension and that can be very
um tough from certain tumor types such
as pancreatic cancer which uses very
desmoplastic and very tough
and so basically you have two goals the
first goal is very obvious you want to
disrupt the exocellular matrix and sell
adhesion components without destroying
integrity of your cell membrane and for
this enzymatic digestion is usually the
most efficient however second goal that
is
often not really well considered is that
you want to preserve yourself as target
candidates of course because if you lose
a lot of these markers just by using
crude or aggressive proteases in the
first hand step then you would also have
a lot of false negatives that you for
sure want to avoid and for this
mechanical disruption usually is the
method of choice however
many cells which are really uh well
associated in the tissue such as the
epithelial tumor cells cannot be derived
efficiently only by mechanical
dissociation usually and most deficient
is a combination of both mechanical and
enzymatic treatment and for this already
many years ago we have developed
optimized solutions
in our tumor dissociation kits for human
but also for mouse where you can get
actually very nice single cell
suspensions of highly viable tumor cells
and also all the other compartments that
you have in the tumor and these cells
are also show improved functionality and
according to the second goal i mentioned
the preservation of key cell surface
antigens and we could actually show by
screening more than 200 epitopes that
we've tested on human and mouse tumors
upon dissociation that only about five
percent of these markers are affected by
our enzyme combination if you compare
this to very aggressive enzymes to
trypsin or um this space usually you see
that more than 50 are affected and
because we are using highly purified
enzymes and a mixture of certain enzymes
we can exactly control the um the
reactivity let's say of these enzymes
and we know that these about five
percent sensitivities come from enzyme
are so if you reduce this you can
preserve all the markers that you that
you have
so you
can refer to these lists can see if your
mark of choice is sensitive or not so
you do not have to do this empirically
in-house and then you can
follow this up reduce enzyme r if
there's a marker actually you're
interested in and that you want to
analyze
and this is the data from these initial
screenings and um for the pdx model this
is just a snapshot because i mentioned
we split many more markers that is just
example redata so what you want to
actually get here is you only have human
tumor cells of course because all the
other cells are mouse tissue so you can
go for on two more binding but you
cannot evaluate off tumor binding of
course so in the first screening we
really go for the specificity on the
tumor and choose markers that are highly
expressed on the human tumor cells in
this setting and then secondly when we
go to primary human tissues you can then
of course
map the marker expression on your tumor
cells but you can also compare it to the
expression for example on immune cells
and other cells that are still present
in the tumor tissue and by this then
together with bioinformatic safety
ranking you can come to a more close
number of markers that are serving as
potential target candidates
so then that brings you to the second
step where you maybe want to then
further analyze and validate your target
candidates on primary adenocarcinomas
but also on normal adjacent tissue and
health situation microarrays and as
mentioned here the tissue specimens are
really the limiting factor so you have
to go for another method and that is uh
usually immunofluorescence multiplex
immunofluorescence either if you uh
compare standard microscopy which easily
can be done in five plex or even some
more but that has to be
tremendously validated
however in this five decks usually you
cannot then always screen five targets
candidates because you also want to have
an idea about the lineages that you have
so you usually stain all the immune
cells and tumor cells to see really the
core expression of your market of
interest so if you want to stain 100
markers you have to do 30 to 50
serial sections
and
as each section is really
similar but still
a little bit different you completely
lose than the single cell information
and that is in particular important if
you want to do correlation analysis
which targets are co-expressed on which
cells
and for this we have developed the
maxima technology and that is a cyclic
immunofluorescence staining method where
you can really go
until several hundred plex marker
analysis on the very same tissue section
so keeping the single cell resolution of
course
and by this you can then of course also
apply the lineage markers and all of
your target candidates in one run and
all stain them on the very same tissue
section
and this is just one example here from
the markers that were interesting from
the flow cytometry and what you see here
in the primary pancreatic duct
adenocarcinoma
and just to
focus on on a few here you see of course
that some are
tumor specific like cd 318 where you see
really a nice correlation of the
epithelial cytokeratin signal and our
markov interest whereas others as
expected like cd59 are not
tumor-specific so they are expressed on
tumor cells but also on stromal cells
and endothelial cells so you can then
exclude such markers from further
analysis
and this of course is very helpful on
the tumor tissue already however
also you want to see the potential on
target of tumor toxicity in other organs
and therefore you can then also use
healthy tissue microarrays like here
where you see again cd 318 being nicely
expressed on pancreatic cancer but not
on the other tissues there's a slight
background expression in the colon but
this is mostly in the mucous region
whereas for example for t span 8 you see
a strong expression in the pancreatic
cancer sample but also very strong
expression in the colon so this target
for sure needs further evaluation but
actually this is very similar for other
targets such as ca which are already
under clinical evaluation and there are
other methods to overcome potential
toxicities such as different routes of
injection or safety switches within the
car t cells
so then upon
having enough validation and confidence
in your target candidates you can go on
for functional evaluation and first of
all you have to then clone this into an
array of car constructs because still so
far it is not possible to purely predict
what car configuration would be optimal
for your target candidate so of course
you can talk about the signaling domains
the transmember intermediates but one
very particular case is also the spacer
domain because for many binders you do
not know where your epitope of binding
is located is it very membrane proximal
or is it
membrane distal and in order to resemble
more or less immunological synapse you
need to really get the right spacer
length in order to target shorter or
longer targets
and therefore we have done so we have uh
yeah cloned scfvs and put them in the
into the cart context and then did a
function analysis and this is just one
example
how this works so we have transduced t
cells with our car constructs and here
you see a mock control so mock
transfused with an irrelevant car or
even gfp
or also car t cells and here you see a
gfp labeled tumor cells and then when
you add
the car t cells or the mock t cells and
then you um
start the killing essay you see that the
car t sets very fast and efficiently
eradicate the tumor cells whereas the
mock t cells cannot do so and this can
also be quantified of course and as you
can see here so you see that some cars
are highly efficient some are
intermediate efficient and some are also
non-functional and next to the pure
killing kinetics of course what is also
very interesting is to get into the
further car phenotyping and this again
is of course done by flow cytometry with
checking for activation and exhaustion
markers such as pd1 but also a cytokine
release
such as interferon gamma but also many
more so here we're using our max plex
flow essay to uh really imperial analyze
a lot of different type of kinds in the
supernatant of such co-cultures
so this is nice but this is all done on
based on functionality on cell lines
tumor cellulites that have been cultured
for decades and not really resemble the
heterogeneity that you find in primary
tumors so we were wondering really what
about the efficacy on primary cells
coming from patient grafts are also
primary tumors and that of course
complicates the whole method because you
cannot start here where you have your t
cell and tumor cell culture and then can
go directly into a functional killing
essay and to phenotyping but you have to
start much earlier with the solid tissue
and again the first step would be sample
preparation i will not go into this
again because we already discussed it so
but then you have two additional steps
first of all you have to isolate your
cells of choice so your tumor cells and
then you have to culture them because in
many cases you might not have enough
material from the beginning so you might
want to at least short-term expand the
tumor cells for your functional essays
but also um you
have to plate them in order to do these
killing assays and that is not so
trivial when you work with primary tumor
cells
so let's start with the isolation of
your target cells and
at milton we have
developed a comprehensive workflows
starting from all different uh materials
oxanografted tumors mouse tumors or
human tumors and then isolate your tumor
cells as today i would only go into
xenograft and human tumors but the
principle is the same for all of them
so let's talk about the xenografts first
and here uh let's say it's a more or
less easy solution because you have
human tumor cells in a mouse context so
what you want to do is you want to
remove all the mouse cells in order to
isolate your tumor cells and therefore
we have done a cell surface marker
screening and have coupled an array of
antibodies to paramagnetic microbeads so
the principle is that after dissociation
you have your mixture of human cells
depicted here in blue and all the
different mouse cells and these
antibodies they recognize all the mouse
cells from all the different tissues and
all the different mouse strains so if
you run this over a column that is
placed in the magnetic field you will
find you are untouched human tumor cells
in the negative fraction if you want you
can also isolate your mouth sets
subsequently and this of course has the
advantage that is completely independent
on any positive marker you need to know
in your tumor cells and therefore it
works also for all kind of different
xenografts even for non-tumor cells so
for example when you graft stem cells
into the mouse you can still get them
back
and this is
when you take the cells in culture so if
you would just culture the original
infection what you see here is that you
have tumor cells that are growing on the
bed of fibroblasts and some other like
macrophages so if you would do a
functional essay on this here it is
would be very hard to dissect what
really comes from your killing of your
target cells and what comes as a bias
just from side effects from
contaminating cell populations whereas
when you isolate your tumor cells and
have to say that this whole method takes
only about 20 minutes then you start
with a pure population and of course
that would not only help you with car t
cells but also when you test biologicals
or small molecules
and then just to make the story a
complete also for the human tumors we
can isolate the tumor cells of course
you're a little bit more difficult
setting because you want to isolate
human tumor cells out of the human
lineage
and
of course when you ask yourself what are
the major contaminants it's of course
the red blood cells
the white blood cells the endothelial
cells and also the fibroblasts
and again we have developed an antibody
cocktail that you can just apply and
also again in 20 minutes get from such a
crude mixture of cells to purified tumor
cells and again if you compare these
cultures as expected uh from the
original infection you have a mixture of
tumor cells that are also in many cases
just overgrown after very few days by
fibroblasts whereas when you isolate
your tumor cells you can have a clean
culture that you can go on for your
functional assay
and this is not only possible for solid
tumor sums but also
let's say for very
challenging summits such as plural
effusion
as shown here for ovarian carcinoma
because there you usually have only one
or two percent tumor cells but still
with the same method you can isolate
such tumor cells and also make them
applicable for functional downstream
analysis or assays
and again just a side note also we do a
lot of sequencing single cell sequencing
but also by uh sequencing and what we've
also seen but of course it can be
expected that when you isolate your
tumor cells and then do a whole exome
sequencing that was done in bulk here uh
of course you get also much higher
sensitivity in the detection of somatic
variants because uh you isolate your
tumor cells from subpopulation to a pure
population so you're not spending a lot
of reads on the cartridge of course on
sequencing cells that you are not
interested in and the same but even more
promising and dramatic what's true of
course for the single cell applications
so then you have isolated your tumor
cells and then you want to culture them
for the killing essay and again this is
very challenging but also for this we
have established a nice workflow
starting as mentioned dissociation
isolation of tumor cells if you want
then you can do the qc by flow cytometry
and then culture these cells either
short term
or to just plate them or maybe a little
bit longer term if you want to expand
them and here what i want to point out
that these are serum free media and that
has the big advantage that um it is
shown that um when you culture tumor
cells in media containing high amounts
of serum for prolonged times these cells
tend to differentiate and also lose the
tumor initiating capacity and this
reward here so these serum free media
allow the culture of tumor cells so far
we have optimized them for four
indications colon carcinoma renal clear
cell care and synonymous ovarian
carcinoma and pancreatic carcinoma and
if you compare for example early and
late passage you see that there is a
preservation of the morphological
heterogeneity we have also done genetic
analysis and flow cytometry to really
prove that this is kept and what is also
very nice when we look here now again
into pancreatic carcinoma that you can
derive it from primary tumors but also
from xenografts from unsorted and
isolated tumor cells but very nice also
you can
get adherent cell cultures but also
suspension cell cultures because we have
seen a trend that many epithelial tumors
tend to better grow in 3d and i have to
say that these are not embedded so these
are just purely grown as turmerics and
our media still nicely supply
them with everything they need to grow
in suspension tumor it's 3d structures
and that is of course can be applied for
more complex co-culture models
and again what is very important and
this is data from the group of andreas
trump
which has initially developed this media
before working with us together on on
the further development and optimization
is that when you compare the patient
originating tumor to the patient you
have seen graft you see what you expect
you nicely resemble the morphology but
what is new now to these media is that
even when you culture them in 2d as
shown here and then re-graft them into a
immunodeficient mouse so a cell culture
derived graph still you see nicely
resembling of the histological features
of the original tumor so they keep their
memory of where they are coming from and
also
look very similar to the pdx models and
that is of course giving you the chance
to also work on these cells and validate
everything later on on these cell line
derived casino graphs still
so with this now we have all the tools
in hand actually to also perform
functional car t-cell killing assays on
primary cells
and this is what we did and here just
some exemplary data and here you can see
aspc one which is established cell line
uh with expressing all the three markers
that we have talked about
but now you can also see cell lines
derived from primary human tumors and
also from xenografts and now you see
also there's an array of different
expression patterns of our target
candidates as it would be in the reality
of clinical samples and so now you can
all use these kind of
primary cultures and also co-culture
them with your car t cells and really
ask yourself the question what
influences the car t-cell activity is it
only the marker expression is it a
co-expression of
immunosuppressive molecules such as pl1
and uh
actually what you see it's uh very
dependent
on the target expression of course
because for example look at this this
part two
celine here
and if i go back to the flow cytometry
you see that this cell line
only expresses cd 318 but not the other
targets and as expected also when you
look here for marker up regulation but
also cytokine release only cd 318 based
cars actually uh efficiently kill his
line up regulate uh activation markers
and also release cytokines
and for example for the aspc one
expressing all the targets you see also
killing of all the car t sets and the
same holds true for this primary derived
cell line from a primary human tumor
so with this you can then also resemble
the heterogeneity in a clinical reality
and also what you see is it's not the
only case the target expression it's
also other factors uh because also the
cell line uh activation pattern is not
always at the same level in each of
these cells
so upon then uh really nicely
characterizing your different car
constructs you of course choose the best
working ones in vitro and then you
perform in vivo studies
and here we have used um
nsg xenograph models with other aspc1 or
bxpc3 and we have injected then car t
cells and what you see here is on this
aspc one model
that cd66s can
can prolong survival of the mice but it
cannot eradicate the tumor and the same
holds true also here for the speak
species 3 model i have to say that this
is very challenging both are very
challenging models because we already
established tumors for almost two weeks
so they are solid masses before we
inject iv the car t cells you see that
tspan8
in particular with the spacer shows a
very nice response with two more
clearing after about 30 days
but only in the aspc one not in the
pxbc3 model so here you all just need
too much stabilization for tspan8 and
this again can be uh dedicated to the
target expression evaluated by flow
cytometry also xvivo uh here you see
tspan8 only very low express on the xpc3
very highly expressed on aspc one cells
and our let's say best candidate cd 318
you see very fast and efficient tumor
relocation even after less than two
weeks in both
models so of course to better understand
why a car t cell is working or not and
then we do ex vivo analysis so we reject
the the tumor or tumor remnants and then
we check this by again the maxima
technology for car t cell infiltration
tumor remnants macrophage infiltration
and target expression and this is of
course accomplished also by in that flow
cytometry analysis again to look for
potential explanations of the indivo
efficacy and for example what you can
see here is that actually cd6's z
function was not
low due to limit of target expression
because you see it's nicely expressed
even x vivo but it was a of obviously a
lag of functional car t-cell
infiltration that you see in cd 318 but
not in 66 c so you see t-cell
infiltration but not active infiltration
of these purple car t-cells here
and of course
to make the story around we also do a
lot of phenotyping on the t cells
isolated x vivo
so we dissociate different organs like
the bone marrow the spleen but also the
tumor isolate based on cd45 positive
enrichment
the car t cells and then we do
phenotyping and quantification of the
cars and their flow cytometry is of
course the method of choice because of
the very nice quantification you can do
but also we look at um
central memory versus effect of
phenotypes because this was shown to
have predictive value later on for the
clinical efficiency when you go for
translation
the last point i want to make here is
that of course this is all either flow
cytometry or 2d spatial resolution but
you might also want to go deeper in the
tissue and also see the 3d context and
that is where we use light sheet
microscopy with our ultra microscopes
which actually give you the opportunity
so in this case we did the labeling even
in vivo so we injected dyes into the
mice but you can also do it ex vivo then
you um
take out the tumor or the organ of
interest you fix it you clear it in
order to make it amendable for um
for a light sheet microscopy and now you
can really see here in green the tumor
cells in orange the vasculature and in
pink you see the cartesia infiltration
into the tumor and you can then of
course also make statistics about the
special distribution of these cells and
thereby derive much more information
about the persistence and proliferation
of the cartisates inside the tumors
so with this i want to thumb up and i
hope i could convince you that we have
provided a comprehensive workflow for
the identification of new target
candidates
here i focus today on car t-sets but
this is of course also applicable to
other cellular therapies and also
biologics that we have developed
solutions to address all the technical
challenges in the functional evaluation
of immunotherapy targets in particular
when working with primary cells
and finally that we also identified for
target candidates for cellular
immunotherapy of pancreatic cancer
showing high tumor specificity very
restricted of tumor expression and i was
not talking about this
but you can also look it up in our
publication that was recently published
in nature medicine sorry in nature
communications about the confident
bioinformatics safety level
and we were able to derive functional
car constructs in vitro and in vivo
so with this i want to thank the people
that really do the work because i'm just
sitting in the office and waiting for
nice data but this is really uh
dedicated to the people in my team uh
that compiled all the data worked on
this and also a lot of military
colleagues because it was a big
interdisciplinary project with
bioinformatics
our t-cell experts and many others
but also corporation partners in
academia and also industry and of course
also you for your attention
thank you olaf for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is how do you remove
the stainings between each cycle in the
maxima
yes thank you very much that's a very
good question
so we're using two different
technologies to do so
the
one and let's say that the first
technology we applied is uh
photobleaching so um we are using um
dyes that are sensitive to bleaching
which are then fine for the imaging but
after each imaging cycle we are then
stitching the dice away and we have also
proven that even if you do a couple of
hundred of stainings that is still
perfectly fine and the tissue integrity
is kept
and as a second removal
mechanism we are using enzymatic removal
of the staining and so we are using both
systems in parallel and also if you
perform one maxima run you can also use
antibody conjugates
which are of the one or the other
technology and use it on the on the very
same instrument in the same run and just
tell the instrument what removal to use
in each cycle
thank you
next question
how do you decide to culture primary
tumor cells in 2d or 3d
yeah
so
that was also let's say a surprise for
us when we started about five or six
years ago with the culturing of primary
tumor cells because the idea was that
most epithelial tumor cells at least
would grow in 2d
at least when you plate them on a
substrate where they are
happy to to adhere however what we have
seen is that in many patient samples
even epithelial tumors like pancreatic
ovarian but also colon carcinoma samples
the cells like more to grow in 3d and
tumors ferroids or organoids
and the let's say that the challenging
part is that you can not really see
before from the patient sample the
diagnosis or the stage if the cells tend
to grow into the 3d so usually what we
do is we dissociate the sample
isolate the tumor cells if needed and
then we plate them on primary surface
plates
so that promote adhesion of the cells
and we have seen that uh if the tumor
cells tend to aggregate and grow in 3d
they still do so when you have them on
these kind of plates so we do not do
initial let's say a matrix gel embedding
or so
and when we then observe during the
first passages that the cells really
like to grow better in 3d then we
usually switch to um
to different surfaces so such as ultra
low attachment plates and then we
culture them just in 3d
but yeah it is very important to really
keep it in mind that even if you culture
epithelial tumor cells and your cells
stay in the supernatant that does not
necessarily mean that they are dead but
they just
can also grow in suspension so it's
definitely good to take these suspension
cells do a live dead cell dye staining
and then check if these cells are still
viable and maybe uh just tend to to grow
so i mean there are some particular
tumors such as colorectal cancers where
there's really a huge trend to grow them
in 3d and then what you can do also
right from the beginning is to embed
them in material
and the good thing is that the media
that we developed are compatible with
these 3d material embedded
and organoculture
as well as for the 2d culture
thank you
next question
what if the enzymes used in the tumor
dissociation step cleaved potential car
targets
yeah a very important point during the
dissociation procedure that you have to
to worry about
as briefly talked about in the
presentation it's really a matter of
using
very purified or highly purified enzymes
because usually what causes the trouble
is not the the enzyme itself but the
residual activities that are still in
the enzyme due to the manufacturing
process
so most enzymes are manufactured from um
from from coot lysates and not
recombinantly
and
that means for example if you're using a
collagenase and that still has a tryptic
or chemotryptic residual activities that
will cleave off your targets because the
collagenase itself is very specific
however a certain amount of these
activities
is also beneficial for in particular
task tissues and that's the reason why
we have this strategy that we use
combinations of enzymes that are each
very pure
so we know exactly which activities
specific unspecific specific activities
they have but then we use a combination
of these highly pure enzymes
to still get a good
dissociation and a high viability but
the advantage here is then now of course
because you have these mixture of highly
purified enzymes that you do not have
this lot to lot inconsistency so you do
not have to worry that one lot might be
great a sensitive epitope whereas the
next slot has a different of the
different behavior and that is really
the the key to do so
and how we check this is
we do
epitope stability tests on very
sensitive systems such as pvmc so we
take cell lines or primary cells blood
cells that express these surface markers
and then we incubate them with the
enzymes
and that is very um sensitive because
there's no extracellular matrix so the
enzymes can really act on the cell
surface proteins and by this you then by
flow cytometry we check if the mean
fluorescence intensity so the signal
strength is going down by the enzyme
incubation different titus
and by this we can really narrow down
what epitope sensitivities we are seeing
in terms of certain epitopes and certain
enzymes and can tightly control this and
by this
you can be sure that you do not have a
lot of false negatives which you would
have when you use either impure enzymes
or very aggressive proteins such as
trypsin or papain or displace or
something like that
hey thank you
next question are you planning on
applying this method to identify targets
and other types of tumors
yes yes so today i was talking about
pancreatic adenocarcinoma
but we are also applying the very same
method to other tumor indications
mostly of course solid tumor indications
because the workflow is really optimized
for solid tumor indications
and i mean our focus is really
immunotherapy so car targets
we are also working with
tcrs
that was not a focus of today because
they are the method of discoveries of
course very different one you're using
more
ngs
applications but still for functionality
testing the very same workflows can be
used as well as for example for
checkpoint inhibition and which is also
applied to multiple two medications
okay
it looks like we have time for one more
question
how did you select the initial antibody
screening panels
um yes so uh
basically we have um
we have a screening plate
it's uh it's it's a plate it's a um
it's a cell surface screening panel and
basically it contains
all the antibodies
that are expressed on cell surface we
have it
for human and um so it's a pre-selection
of let's say of all the portfolio
antibodies that are directed to work in
such essays
and um
this is also constantly updated so the
the portfolio is expanding and therefore
also these screening plates get
get larger
and
what we then sometimes add if they are
not anyway in these screening plates is
for example targets that are known from
other tumor indications and where
antibodies that are amendable for either
immune isochemistry or flow cytometry in
particular as i showed today
are available then we add them to the
place
thank you olaf do you have any final
comments for our audience
yeah i mean i would like uh to thank you
all for uh depending on your time zone
getting up very early or staying very
long
for
the presentation today and i hope um you
liked it and enjoyed it and yeah if any
question comes up in the in the future
please just get in touch with us thanks
a lot
thank you again olaf for your time today
in your presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye